CITY COUNCIL AND THE SHERIFF,
MAY BE WARD AND ALSO.
THAT IS THE KIND OF PROGRESS WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT YOUR PEERS
MARKET IS THE EDITOR OF
DailyMail.com, AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT THAT WITHOUT MOCKING
THIS, LET'S TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY FOR A SECOND, THE IDEA
THAT PEOPLE CURRENTLY BEHIND
BARS, WHO HAVE NOT COMPLETED
THEIR SENTENCES BUT ARE SERVING
THEM, SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
CHOOSE OUR LEADERS, IS THIS A
GOOD IDEA?
>> YOU KNOW, TUCKER, I WAS
WATCHING THE CNN TOWN HALL WHEN
BERNIE SANDERS SAID WHAT HE SAID
ABOUT THE BOSTON MARATHON
BOMBER, AND I LITERALLY SPAT MY
DRINK OUT.
IT WAS A NICE GLASS OF RED WINE,
SO IT WAS A SENSELESS WASTE OF
GOOD ALCOHOL.
I STARTED OUT, I COULDN'T
BELIEVE WHAT I WAS HEARING FOR
THIS IS A GUY COMING FRONT
RUNNER, AS YOU SAID, TO BE THE
POTENTIAL NOMINEE FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO BEAT
DONALD TRUMP, THAT IS THEIR PLAN
AND WHAT WANT TO DO.
AND THEIR MAIN SELLING POINT
RIGHT NOW ON A CNN TOWN HALL IS
THEY WANT THE BOSTON MARATHON
BOMBER TO BE ABLE TO VOTE WHILE
HE IS IN PRISON?
WHILE HE IS ON DEATH ROW?
AND WHILE YOU SAY DO NOT LOCK
IT, HOW CAN WE NOT?
THIS IS THE STUFF OF ULTRA
LUNACY.
IT IS THE KIND OF STUFF --
WATCHING THE SHOW FOR A LONG
TIME, THIS KIND OF INVASION OF
WOKE THOUGHT, WHICH IS NOW
REALLY SENDING PEOPLE NUTS, I
THINK IT IS NOW BEING EXTENDED
TO AREAS LIKE THE PENAL SYSTEM.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT THIS AND
SAYING "THAT MAKES PERFECT
SENSE, IT MAKES PERFECT SENSE
THAT RAPISTS, PEDOPHILES,
TERRORIST, PEOPLE GUILTY OF
TREASON, MASS MURDERERS, SERIAL
KILLERS, THEY SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT TO VOTE, THAT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING."
HERE'S WHAT I'VE ASKED THEM, AND
THERE IS AN IRONY OF ME PUTTING
THIS QUESTION, WHAT YOU WILL
MEET AT THE UNDERSTAND, BUT IF
YOU ASK THE VERY SAME DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES WHO SUPPORT, WHO WANT
THE RIGHT TO VOTE TO EXIST FOR
FELONS --
>> Tucker: I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO SAY.
>> HOW THEY WOULD FEEL ABOUT THE
RIGHT TO OWN OR BUY A GUN.
I WOULD LOVE IT IF SOMEBODY WHO
HAS A VIEW COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
TO YOU ABOUT GUN CONTROL, I
WOULD LOVE IT IF FELONS, TREATED
AS THEY ARE, ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
HAVE GUNS.
THEY ARE NOT.
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR A FELON
IN AMERICA TO COME OUT, THEY HAD
MORE THAN A ONE YEAR SENTENCE
TWO, TO OWN OUR BUY A GUN.
LOGICALLY SPEAKING, THAT IS AN
INFRINGEMENT ON THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
SO WHY AREN'T THEY CAMPAIGNING
AT THE SAME TIME FOR FELONS TO
HAVE THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
OWN AND BUY A GUN?
>> ON WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IS WE
DON'T TRUST YOU TO GO DEER
HUNTING, BUT WE WANT YOU TO
CHOOSE OUR LEADERS, OUR NEXT
PRESIDENT.
WHAT THEY ARE REALLY SAYING IS
WE DON'T CARE AT ALL ABOUT
ANYTHING, WHERE NIHILIST, ALL WE
WANT IS POWER, AND IF WE SEE A
RESERVOIR OF POTENTIAL VOTERS,
WE WILL TAP THAT.
>> YOU TOUCHED ON ANOTHER ISSUE,
A SERIOUS ONE, WHICH IS LOOK AT
THE VOTING INTENTIONS OF SOME OF
WHAT THESE FELONS WOULD BE
HAVING.
SAY YOU ARE A CONVICTED MASS
RAPISTS, RAPED 20 WOMEN, HOW ARE
YOU GOING TO CAST YOUR VOTE IF
YOU ARE ALLOWED TO VOTE?
IT WILL NOT BE FOR ANYONE
PROMOTING THE SAFETY OF WOMEN.
SO THERE IS A DIRECT
CONSEQUENCE, A DIRECT ELECTORAL
VOTE IN CONSEQUENCE, IN ALLOWING
SERIOUS OFFENDERS TO VOTE.
I WOULD EXTENDED -- I WOULDN'T
ALLOW ANY FELONS TO VOTE AT ALL,
WHILE THEY ARE IN PRESENT HERE
THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED TO WALK OUT
FREE, BACK INTO THE STREETS.
DON'T LET ANYBODY HAVE A VOTE
WHILE THEY ARE THERE, THAT IS
WHAT PUNISHMENT IS ABOUT IT.
YOU LOSE YOUR RIGHTS TO A NORMAL
LIFE.
I WOULD EXTENDED, CERTAINLY FOR
ANYTHING OVER THE MOST TINY,
MINUSCULE OFFENSES.
LOOK, YOU CAN COME OUT, AND WE
ARE GOING TO WATCH YOU FIVE
YEARS, AND WE ARE GOING TO SEE
IF YOU'RE GENUINELY
REHABILITATED.
IF YOU DON'T REOFFEND IN FIVE
YEARS, SADLY MANY FELONS DO, IF
YOU DON'T REOFFEND, THEN WE WILL
LOOK AT YOU AT IF WE PROCEEDED
NOT TO BE A THREAT TO SOCIETY,
NOT TO BE A POTENTIAL REOFFEND
THERE, THEN WE MAY CONSIDER
RESTORING YOUR RIGHT TO VOTE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
BUT I CERTAINLY WOULDN'T EVER
EXTEND IT ANYONE GUILTY OF ANY
MAJOR, SERIOUS OFFENSE, WHETHER
THEY ARE IN PRISON OR WHETHER
THEY GET LET OUT LATER ON.
TO ME, AT SOME POINT, THERE HAS
TO BE GENUINE PUNISHMENT.
FOR SERIOUS OFFENSES.
YOU DON'T GET TO VOTE.
>> Tucker: WE WANT A COUNTRY
THAT IS WELL-RUN.
THE ENFRANCHISEMENT OF EVERYONE
IS A GOAL, BUT THE OVERARCHING
GOAL IS A PEACEFUL, PLACID,
NONCORRUPT, PROSPEROUS, WELL-RUN
COUNTRY, RIGHT?
SO WHY WOULD YOU EVER WANT --
>> AND THERE IS AN IRONY,
TUCKER, THE SAME DEMOCRATS
SCREAMING EVERY SINGLE SECOND OF
EVERY DAY ABOUT TRUMP AND
COLLUSION, HE IS A CRIMINAL, WE
CAN'T HAVE A CRIMINAL RUNNING
THE COUNTRY, AND YET AT THE SAME
TIME, THEY ARE CAMPAIGNING FOR
EVERY CRIMINAL IN THE COUNTRY TO
HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE FOR
PRESIDENT.
AGAIN, THIS IS FULL OF LUDICROUS
IRONY, SO WHEN YOU SAY TO ME,
PIERS, I DON'T WANT YOU TO MOCK
THIS, I AM FINDING THAT
INSTRUCTION VERY DIFFICULT,
MR. CARLSON.
>> Tucker: YOU WOULD HAVE TO
THINK, IF YOU ARE THE DEMOCRATS
AND ALL YOU CARE ABOUT IS TAKING
POWER, SEIZING IT BACK FROM THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, THAT YOU
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THIS THROUGH.
THERE ARE SMART PEOPLE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE, RUTHLESS
PLAYERS, NOTHING THEY HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THE LAST TWO
MONTHS HAS BROUGHT OR EVEN
MAJORITY APPEAL IN THIS COUNTRY
FAIR THEY ARE LOSING THE
ELECTION ALREADY.
WHY ARE THEY DOING THIS?
WHAT IS HAPPENING?
>> I THINK THEY ARE ON A
POLITICAL SUICIDE MISSION, AND
I'VE SAID THIS FOR QUITE SOME
TIME HERE THAT I DEALT WITH THE
MUELLER COLLUSION OF SESSION,
WHICH MANY OF THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA HAVE HAD, MANY DEMOCRATS
HAVE HAD, ALL OF THE USUAL
SUSPECTS, DEMOCRATS, HAVE HAD.
AT THIS COLLUSION OBSESSION HAS
TURNED OUT, AS IT HAD, THAT
MUELLER FIND OUT THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION, THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
ACT AS ONE OF THE GREAT BOATING
BONUSES FOR DONALD TRUMP
IMAGINABLE.
IT WAS TWO YEARS OF THE
ESTABLISHMENT, THE MEDIA,
CELEBRITIES TRYING TO DEPOSE HIM
AS PRESIDENT, BASICALLY A FAKE
NEWS STORY THAT HE COLLUDED WITH
THE RUSSIANS.
SO HERE WE ARE, WE ARE NOW 18
MONTHS FROM AN ELECTION, AND THE
DEMOCRATS, RATHER THAN JUST TAKE
THEIR PUNISHMENT ON THE MUELLER
REPORT AND SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT,
THERE WASN'T COLLUSION, MUELLER,
OUR KNIGHT IN SHINING ARMOR, HAS
CONCLUDED THAT, SO WE NEED TO
MOVE ON AND TRY TO GET BEHIND
THE CANDIDATE WHO HAS A
POSITIVE, BRILLIANT IDEA AND
DIVISION FOR THE COUNTRY, WHICH
THEY CAN OFFER UP AGAINST TRUMP,
WHO THEY SEE AS THEIR NEMESIS.
INSTEAD, HE OF ALL OF THESE
CANDIDATES LAST NIGHT, LED BY
BERNIE SANDERS, KAMALA HARRIS,
WHO WAS A LAWYER FOR GOODNESS
SAKE, ALL BASICALLY STANDING
THERE SAYING "HERE IS A GREAT
IDEA TO WIN OVER MIDDLE AMERICA,
THE HEARTLAND THAT DONALD TRUMP
GOT AWAY FROM US IN THAT LAST
ELECTION.
WE ARE GOING TO REALLY CAMPAIGN
WITH THE BOSTON MARATHON BOMBER
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO VOTE."
WHAT PART OF THAT DOES NOT
SCREAM TO THE DEMOCRATIC
LEADERSHIP, THIS IS MADNESS!
THIS IS A WAY TO GET TRUMP
REELECTED.
MAYBE THEY ARE ALL SLEEPER CELLS
APPEARED TO BE WHEN I'M THINK
THAT.
TSARNAEV SHOULD BE VOTING?
UNBELIEVABLE.